is it weird to ask about tongue
evolution did they evolve early on and
why such versatile uses for instance
cats dogs people and chameleons
and i thought i used to talk about tons
so i searched on tongues on my computer
and i found this
zachary
this is a slide from a lecture i used to
give on the origin of tetrapods
life on land feeding
water currents can be used to manipulate
food in the mouth actinopterygians
that's refined fish like salmon and
mudskippers are great at this but this
isn't possible in the air so food
manipulation in tetrapods is usually
accomplished with a
fleshy muscularized tongue
this is it is imagined and then there's
also i think
here we go i also found this
which is some of the research excuse me
um
that i used for this little tiny piece
of this lecture on the evolution of
tetrapods
a review from 2002 called the evolution
of the structure and function of the
vertebrate tongue and iwasaki here the
author of this paper also talks about
basically you don't need when you're in
water
to have something in your mouth that is
muscularized by which you're moving food
around because you can use water
currents or you can make your own water
current by moving yourself through the
water to do that to get the food where
it needs to go that's completely
fascinating yeah so this is like this
was one of my favorite lectures that i
that i created and that i used to get
like what are all the things that you
suddenly have to solve once you've moved
to land yeah and one of the things is
once you've got food into your mouth how
do you get it where it needs to go
within your mouth like to your choppers
and back into your throat like you use
your tongue
so this is this is a life on land
solution
how if i missed that it's totally as
it fits yeah it totally it totally fits
the tongue appears to be a not a
vertebrate
uh
snap morphe i mean like some actin
operations have like a little protrusion
but it's not dense doesn't tend to be
uh muscularized it's not very big and
then at the point you got tetrapods you
got all these crazy
um
crazy new things going on like frogs
um
gosh i think it's all frogs but maybe
it's just the frogs with which i am most
familiar the tongues are connected at
the front of their mouths
and so they flip them out
i know it's ridiculous
it's unholy it's it's unholy and then
let's see is it um
is it
woodpeckers
that it's like
it's wrapped around the back of their
skull
uh and then they can
i could i could look up woodpeckers here
too and see if i have a woodpecker image
i probably do
um
and whatever let's you you just keep
talking about tongues if you will i'm
going to say i'm wondering so there are
a lot of aquatic creatures that are
secondarily aquatic that have returned
to the sea and i am betting based on
what you have just informed me of that
they spend a lot of their time sticking
their tongues at
the prima the fundamentally primarily
aquatic creatures who cannot stick their
tongues back out i would imagine that
happens a lot i think that's happening
all the time
yep all the time yeah um i probably i
gave i had so many different versions of
pretty big evolution
and i'm oh
no we got cranial kinesis
yeah i'm going to have to think about
this more i would cranial can it sounds
like you're speaking in tongues
um cranial kinesis no i got it i know
you got it i know i know you guys
cravings cranial's head kinesis kinetic
means movement so um there are a lot of
different evolutions of the head bones
the various head bones moving relative
to one another and so
uh when you hear things like oh my god
that snake can literally unhinge its jaw
like now they don't unhinge their jaw in
order to you know eat something bigger
than its head but they have a
joint that is an addition to our joint
and so they can get a gape that's bigger
than we would be able to given um where
uh the two main pieces of the jaw the
upper and lower jaw are actually
attached uh so and then i would i would
love to do it over evolution again i
would have to teach that
again
this all raises a question though yeah
um the
the phrase he she or it has become
unhinged is that a reference to snakes
do you think um probably yeah yeah i
think it probably is
except actually i think it's a reference
to a door flapping in the wind or
something yeah no i think that's
actually it but it'd be better if it was
a reference to snakes yeah um so yeah
then the rest of the question about
tongues which obviously i could spend a
lot of time talking about um why such
versatile use and with yeah i have a
hard time actually i can i can i can
talk with my fingers too
yeah yeah that's spreading yeah that is
great uh why such versatile uses cats
dog peep dogs people chameleons well
given that we now know that this is
really a tetrapod synapomorphy being a
characteristic that was
derived at the origin of tetrapods and
um and shared among them then you start
to see diversification and so um you
know frogs with their tongues attached
in the front
at least some frogs uh chameleons
uh with the curled up tongue that then
can be sort of like unfurled like a one
of those like what it looks like party
party popper things
but those have a name they yeah it's not
a popper it's i don't know what they're
called exactly but that's kind of what
um i somewhere on this computer too i
have a slow-motion video of chameleons
hunting with their
friend brad moon gave me at one point
um he was a much
much better herpetologist than i am and
so of course he has slow motion videos
of chameleon tongues christmas does yeah
as one does
um
so really it's just about
diversification once you know
fit in the tongue fits the job and given
the tongue originally is about
being able to move food around in
uh the mouth once you're in air where
the air that can't help you whereas the
water could uh now they're also you know
you can use it if you're one of these
guys one of these epic tabbies uh to
clean yourself or to lick the vitamin d
off your fur apparently vitamin df
you're freaking away better explanation
than cleaning themselves i think it's
both
probably a bit of both yeah um but
there's also
navigation oh
yes okay
the fork and tongue of the snake oh and
the vomero nasal organ and the fact that
these
actually first yes yes
the molecules in front of it in two
different directions hence the
forkedness of the tongue and figures out
which way to go based on which direction
tastes right yes yes so you might what
what you all should have been wondering
is if there's a use for two eyes by
which we can get information from two
slightly different places and thus get
depth perception and there's a use for
two ears
by which sound is coming in at two to
slightly different places by which we
can get sound perce depth perception
sound and two nostrils why not two tons
so
we don't have them and indeed i think uh
birds no birds do no endotherms do
i think no species wide endothermic
they're of course anomalies
but and i don't think the non-snake
squad mates do any of them yeah maybe
well maybe
maybe
but uh yeah snakes snakes use the two
tips of the tongue to triangulate odors
and to get a sense of direction then yes
they can have they don't i don't think
they don't i don't think we think that
they
navigate across landscapes doing this
but they sort of they follow scent
profiles towards prey they don't like
they're it's not about oh i'm trying to
get home get into the movies
although i don't know i don't know
you know it's possibly just for lack of
i'll bet that i bet that happens some
given yeah given that the
the basics are there but yeah the fork
and tongue nice does this and uh
this is also the origin of the
expression
his viewpoint is all forked up
is it yes yes yes and it's always his
isn't it
often often yeah
[Music]